el ramadán arrancó oficialmente una
fecha muy señalada para todo el mundo de
creencia musulmana un mes sagrado de
ayuno oración y meditación en el que los
creyentes ayunarán desde la salida del
sol hasta su puesta en un intervalo de
entre 12 y 18 horas
en este mes de ramadán rezamos para que
mi familia y yo seamos bendecidos y nos
convirtamos en personas dignas de
confianza y más sabias ya
es que el ramadán es todo un viaje
espiritual los musulmanes creen que es
el mes en que los primeros versículos
del Corán fueron revelados al profeta
Mahoma además de 1400 años y el ayuno
implica abstenerse de comer beber fumar
o mantener relaciones sexuales durante
el día para alcanzar una mayor tacua o
conciencia de Dios Y ser más sabios el
ramadán también tiene un fuerte
componente familiar ya que es tradición
reunirse en las noches para compartir la
comida al romper el ayuno algo que este
podría resultar más complejo debido al
repunte de la inflación y la subida de
los precios de la comida y la energía en
muchos países de mayoría musulmana
los precios de todos los productos han
estado aumentando todos ellos están
disponibles pero son más altos y los
ingresos de la gente son más bajos la
situación económica no es buena
en los países con los precios más altos
Es probable que muchas personas tengan
que reducir las celebraciones
tradicionales desde la comida típica
como dátiles a pasteles o galletas hasta
los regalos y muchas familias tendrán
que recurrir incluso a organizaciones de
ayuda humanitaria
[Música]